un gesto de Victoria para sus
partidarios rodeado por las fuerzas de
seguridad inmram ham salió del tribunal
como un hombre libre después de que se
le concediera la Libertad bajo fianza
tras la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
Pakistán que declaró su arresto inválido
e ilegal hoy le digo a toda la nación
que el tribunal me ha concedido la
Libertad bajo fianza en todos los casos
y que no hay ningún caso contra mí en
este momento soy un hombre libre a pesar
de todo esto me han secuestrado la
atención dejarán provocó un gran
malestar en el país con algunos
enfrentamientos violentos entre las
fuerzas del orden y Los partidarios del
ex capitán de la selección nacional de
crickets los manifestantes habían
prometido continuar hasta la liberación
del ex jefe de gobierno de 70 años fuera
de su casa la noticia fue recibida con
alegría y júbilo
es una decisión sensata apartará
estabilidad a nuestro país Esperamos que
nuestros tribunales sigan tomando
decisiones sensatas como esta y
conduzcan al país hacia un futuro mejor
con la decisión del tribunal queda
protegido de nuevas detenciones durante
dos semanas en relación con el caso de
corrupción al que se le vincula pero
todavía podría enfrentarse acciones
ilegales por docenas de casos más
incluido uno por fraude desde que fue
destituido como Primer Ministro el
pasado mes de abril Jam sigue siendo un
líder muy popular entre la oposición y
ha emprendido una desafiante campaña
contra el poderoso ejército del país